this is from NBC Boston
GOP activist and lawyer stabbed to death
in his Durham New Hampshire Home full
stop
we have no idea what happened it is
entirely possible that this guy had a
bad poker game and then somebody got mad
at him no idea he could have been
cheating on his wife and then she comes
home and says Ah and then they fight and
then she stabs him we have no idea
however
not knowing the issue is typically that
whenever we get a news story about a
victim who is left with no no no let me
stop I'll put it this way when Jesse
Smollett comes out and claims some guys
threw a noose around his neck the whole
world shuts down every television
network runs a tribute you get uh at the
time Ellen Page saying
like frantically randomly because some
guy hate crime hoaxed all of us
and then when you get a story about a
GOP lawyer being stabbed to death it's
like well you know we don't know exactly
so let's move on from this that's why I
think this story matters because maybe
people on the right be it post-liberal
libertarian whatever you want to call
yourself should start saying when these
things happen we make the Assumption in
the worst until we learn otherwise
because they went balls to the wall for
Jesse Smollett so how about we say we
demand answers as to what happened to
this GOP lawyer who got stabbed to death
in his own home the police are claiming
with self-defense I'm sorry it's going
to be difficult for you to convince me
and it's possible that a person in his
own home was killed in self-defense by a
different person it's possible you know
you invite someone to your house and
then you have the intent of hurting them
they defend themselves it can happen
but still
lawyer in his own house stabbed to death
I'm not leaning towards self-defense
here but I don't know everything I don't
know
it's hard because they're like no
arrests made we're 12 hours out there's
one article up from a local news station
saying they've identified the person
involved but they haven't decided what's
going on I mean
the longer there are no answers in
communication the more suspicious it
gets the easier it is to let sort of the
conspiracy theory run wild uh the day
after Jesse smell like this has been a
week the day after Jesse Smith how about
uh the Bubba rope incident right the
NASCAR thing it is national news
headlines everywhere and now we have
this story and and everyone's been like
well you know hold on there a minute you
know we don't know for sure and it's
which is the reasonable take exactly
like this is how everyone should respond
to stuff like this exactly let's find
out the facts no exactly that's why I
said in the beginning for all we know
like I had a bad poker game yeah but I
think the issue here is
I I'm gonna lean towards you know in the
back of my mind political
because when it comes to instances of
mass tragedies and the perpetrators left
wing they disappear
whenever the bad guy whenever the person
committing the crime happens to fall
into the alignment of the corporate
narrative it's like oh can't have that
one getting out and the story
vanishesville versus Nashville just
going to say that yeah the main festos
yeah that's right or how about uh the
guy who rammed the Christmas parade in
uh uh what was that Waukesha and then it
was just like no idea a truck did it a
truck crashed into these people in the
literal same city where the Kyle
Rittenhouse uh shootings happened no
that was Kenosha
okay so but but I think they were
triggered by the same a couple days
after uh because we were in Austin at
the time and we it was actually
buttonhouse had just gotten I think
within 48 hours so they were right next
to each other uh uh the guy had had some
like BLM related stuff on his Facebook
page but also he had like
crashed his car into his like child's
mother before driving to the the parade
I mean obviously it was a very unstable
person and then he represented to try
and get a sandwich remember yes and he
represented himself at trial which was
something to behold did you see that
trial oh I watched a lot of it I covered
up for the site the patience that judge
had I thought that judge should get him
I mean because part of it was like he
just kept interrupting like you're
saying you know when you don't believe
in what the courts are ruling you can
kind of defy them it also turns out that
if you don't want to follow the
procedures of the Court it is
challenging to enforce uh anything and
also ensure the person who's
representing themselves gets a fair
trial he had to keep getting sent to the
to another room to watch virtually and
then it's a question of like can he
accurately represent himself uh this is
a tan this is an aside but you know the
in the case of this lawyer what's hard
is like either way loss of life very sad
you know the police in this town are
saying there's no threat to the public
so it's sort of playing I I actually
think it's leaning towards domestic
violence
but like it is Extreme really difficult
I totally get you don't want to jump the
gun and blow something up that you're
giving the police a chance to accurately
investigate on the other hand it is hard
to say this is a pretty a fairly
prominent political figure in a state
that's the first in the nation to
primary so we kind of need some
information here as soon as possible and
and this past week the GOP was arguing
over whether or not to remove Trump from
the ballot so I I don't care to give
anyone the benefit of the doubt and my
bigger concern is as a reasonable person
you're right domestic probably seems
like what this may be the person who had
identified may be a significant other
and that's why they're like oh my God
and they're saying self-defense like who
else would be right yeah who else would
be defending themselves in this guy's
right not a visitor but someone who
actually lives there as well uh that
being said if the uh Freedom faction of
individuals whatever you want to call
that uh the anti-establishment faction
does not get serious in their propaganda
game they lose and I don't mean to just
lie I mean to make no noise at the very
least when on the merits of being
reasonable that's why I opened the
segment by saying probably a bad poker
game who knows but be noisy enough about
it to force the conversation
because in the event that there is uh
and there have been like Aaron Danielson
for instance someone shot and killed in
the streets of I think it was Portland
right it was uh Portland by a far left
extremist Michael reinol these stories
need to get Max attention when Andy
knows mercilessly beaten and attacked
with the concrete milkshakes in in uh
was that Portland as well right yeah uh
that forced even Brian stelter to say
okay you know we got to talk about this
because it's like going massively viral
those images everywhere attention needs
to be brought to it and those are those
are the victories where you can start to
to convince these regular people who
don't pay attention
there's something going on here and I'll
give it I'll give a specific example
Oliver Anthony right he gets really
really big he issues these statements
after the fact like why is Fox News
playing my video haha it's about them he
says it's not about politics it's not
because he does not know what the
culture war is everything he sings about
and he's a good avatar for this
everything he sings about representing
Working Class People is effectively a
right quote-unquote culture War right
position but then he doesn't understand
because he's not involved deeply in it
so in the media attacks him and calls
him conservative right wing and the left
says anything he's like no no it's not
left or right I don't know what you're
talking about it's just my lived
experience well he didn't even have a
Twitter account until August yeah and
now here he is and that's my point these
regular people you go to them they don't
understand the depravity and the evil of
the uniparty neocon neolibs all of these
warmongers and this garbage they don't
get it the Jesse Smollett stuff the woke
corporations they think well you know
I'm gonna be somewhere in the middle but
they don't pay attention and then when
you actually engage and you say
something like look I'm not here to
argue about policy or anything like that
but it is true that Joe Biden fire got
that prosecutor fired while threatening
to withhold a billion dollars as soon as
you say that you're right wing my
favorite thing is when he said you got
money for Foreign Wars you can't feed
the poor it's like that's a right-wing
talking point because the left says
sacrifice for Ukraine right it's like
you're in the politics dude my point is
normies don't get it and if you're loud
enough and we bring up more stories like
this and we question these things maybe
they might start to see more of the of
the issue all of no go ahead no Bible
Oliver Anthony is kind of the
personification of what Pericles said
long ago which is you may not be
interested in politics but politics are
interested in you and we're seeing that
this is a guy who you know writes songs
and he did one about his frustration
with how things are going and it was I
mean there was a political element to it
but the guys clearly does not want to be
political uh and it seems like the rest
of his songs aren't political to speak
of and he's been thrust into this into
this political battle he didn't want to
be a part of and you know I
a part of me wants him to just be able
to just be a guy who's making songs
unfortunately he's being dragged into
something he didn't even want to be a
part of which speaks to what you're
talking it's because there is a culture
war no you do not exactly as you
mentioned Pericles I think he said right
uh you may not be interested in politics
politics is interested in you there's
nothing you can do about it we're in a
culture War if we were if it was 20 30
years ago you can say I don't care for
Democrats or Republicans leave me alone
and people might be like okay I get it
today doesn't matter the moment he said
miners on an island somewhere far right
yeah that was it and then they started
accusing him of being q-anon and he was
like I'm not political that song's about
Joe but Joe Biden's the one funding the
Foreign Wars and at the very least while
there are many Republicans who want war
there are many who don't yeah so there's
a debate happening over there and not
one happening over there it is clearly
about more about one side than the other
the other thing too I mean you were
talking about 20 years ago the culture
war and it's like 20 years ago is about
when um Arts artists and art
programs and all that kind of thing
started saying that you have to be an
art activist and politics started being
really infused into art programs which
is when I was in grad school and that's
what it all turned into like I was
studying theater and the next thing I
know it's not about telling a good story
it's not about making something
beautiful it's about infusing your work
with political narrative so that started
there and it's been pushing out this
whole way and now we see you know like
Oliver Anthony can't get a song out
without it being part of the culture War
but like also you kind of need to know
where your where you're squatting down
you know what I mean like take a look
around yeah I I I right I gotta
completely agree with that the dude uh
it's an awesome song I I love Richmond
north of Richmond obviously everybody
loves it because it's good
but the dude is he personifies in many
ways a regular person and I mean this
with no disrespect no like literally
just right yep seeing a lot of these
problems we could all kind of identify
while being lied to by the corporate
press he did criticize them for it but
my criticism back is my dude you must
pay attention you must recognize who
your enemies are and who your friends
are and I'm not saying the Republicans
are your friends by no stretch of the
imagination Nikki Haley was up on stage
screaming lies about Putin wanting to
invade NATO so she can justify her in
saying warmongering yeah Republicans are
mostly bad as well but
you need to recognize who will come
after you when you say something like
miners on an island somewhere right it
is going to be the politicians who are
on that plane who are typically aligned
with the establishment and their
corporate allies
well and this is I mean this comes down
to another way of saying you may not be
interested in politics but politics is
interested in you is you may not be
interested in democracy but democracy is
interested in you when more and more
decisions that are being made aren't we
aren't allowing individuals to make them
we're democratizing them what happens is
that means that someone has to win which
means everyone else has to lose and the
people that lose have the winners
opinion enforced on them whatever that
thing is so it becomes less and less
about I disagree with how you live or
what your opinion is you disagree about
it but we're living separately it's one
of us has to win so now someone that you
disagree with is your enemy and so of
course the culture war is only going to
get worse and worse as things are more
centralized and democratized and the
answer obviously is the opposite
decentralization allowing individuals to
make their own decisions
that was one of the things I liked about
Oliver Anthony's rise was that it comes
from a kind of growing area of music I
mean it wasn't from I don't know where
music is headquartered in in the US I
guess Hollywood and Nashville depending
on what you're doing yeah it's sort of
this this other alternative for music
that's getting popular right now I think
there is a desire to decentralize our
sort of cultural uh cap zones but it's
very difficult because I think that's
not what uh the system to give it a
broad term wants you to do well it's the
I think the art forms that are the most
accessible for decentralization are
comedy and music you know and so I think
that that's in part why we're seeing
um more Counter Culture people coming
out in music and comedy but we're not
seeing that as much in film you know it
takes an awful lot of money to create an
independent film or a series you know or
a theater performance or or if you're an
actor if you get that black ball in your
file like no one's going to want to hire
you that's why I think we were all there
on strike now which I actually think is
a boon to culture I think that's a great
thing thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time